You are an amazing singer, but I wonder how critical are you about yourself after performances?
I'm like my harshest critic.
I'm never satisfied with my performance,...
...but I'm not too hard on myself,...
...but at the same time, I don't think that you can think that you're amazing every time.
You have to have something to critique yourself on,...
...otherwise you're gonna get conceited and that's not so good.
You have to always make believe that there's room to improve.
So, how do you think did you do at the Olympics?
Oh, that one? Actually, I was really happy with that one.
That was the one performance where I was just completely satisfied.
So, tell us about the album.
How would you describe it?
It's very eclectic.
There's a lot of different genres on there.
It's kind of just like me, you know.
You get to know me through the music which is really great.
It's like, you know, you hear the covers here who influenced me.
And then you go to the original songs and you see how they influenced me.
So, I cover all the original songs except for one,...
...so you also get to see how I think, the words and stuff.
Is there a particular theme to the album?
There's basically Nikki, you know, that's the name.
It's just kind of getting to know me.